server Kumar Kennedy is struggling the
46 year old taxi driver is the only one
employed in his 11-member family
we earn less and it's not enough earlier
say we made three to five thousand
rupees a day that was enough now three
thousand rupees is nothing
once we bought the food there's nothing
left so how do we pay for water
electricity schooling extra classes or
any extras a foreign currency shortage
in 2022 left Sri Lanka bankrupt and
unable to pay for food medicine and fuel
Imports causing its worst economic
crisis ever
after defaulting on its loans the
government brought in major economic
reforms to secure a bailout by the
international monetary fund
these included higher taxes an increase
in the cost of electricity water and
fuel and an end to subsidies
the IMF money has helped though many say
it has come at two higher price
we can't afford to give the children
nutritious food paying for their score
is very difficult they've got caned or
kept out of class because the school
couldn't take what was asked for
the couple's younger Sons haven't gone
to school for over a year the IMF is
reviewing Sri Lanka's performance before
releasing another 330 million dollars in
funding
it's asked for a report on governance
and Corruption widely believed to be the
main cause for the economic crisis we
have to make this crisis an opportunity
for Sri Lanka
to
adopt the best practices and ensure that
we become a corrupt free
a country with transparency a country
with accountability where all investors
will have confidence in coming and
investing in Sri Lanka meanwhile leading
Civil Society has made their own
recommendations to fight corruption that
is Hope because the next year is
probably the most crucial year in the
life of this country where the elections
will become a place where their
legitimacy is tested and I think the
second is because we have realized
that governance is too important to be
left to the governors accountability is
the one word that is at the heart of
this diagnostic not accountability to
Human Rights commissions abroad but
accountability to the people of Sri
Lanka for how the economy is governed
many have welcomed the end of queues
adequate Fuel and lower inflation but
they warn if meaningful changes are not
made in governance any relief will be
temporary Mina Fernandez Al Jazeera
Colombo